you can make someone laugh he makes me
listen ever since I was a kid all I've
ever wanted to do was make movies and TV
shows my first feature film only movie
called supersize me and then we went to
Sundance in the film just took off in a
way that none of us expected I'm that
guy who made that movie for nothing that
now in my life will never be the same
hey I'm Morgan Spurlock and these are my
10 essentials this right here this is
the perfect thing I need this whole
plate of bacon while I'm doing this
interview coffee I can't live without
the ritual of a cup of coffee every day
I got an iPhone and now I'm completely
addicted like my whole life is in this
little world right here like if
something happened to this I don't know
what I would do if you ever see anyone
on a payphone that person's not having a
good day and what's the one thing that's
better than bacon and coffee the Piney
gonna use it long day like have goodness
in the morning with bacon this is the
other thing I can't live without and
it's not spam because I can live without
spam but it's Monty Python and spam for
those of you who are Monty Python fans
will understand why if you're not you
should watch somebody Python then you'll
get it I grew up in a house where
laughter was so important and and having
fun and it's like I love being
surrounded by laughter I love it with my
family I love it with my kid I love it
when I'm at work our office is such a
fun place to work and that's the
environment I want to live in and
breathe in that's what my life's kind of
been been pushed by a real key thing for
me is to try to find time to take a
vacation that's what this is this is
vacations oh who does want to be there
ever since I was driving around in my
Camaro in West Virginia yeah that's how
cool I was Camaro
I just love Metallica I'm losing my hair
I'm completely going bald but the hairs
that I still have I like keeping them
down with this I used to use a lot of
product that would make my hair like
stiff and crunchy and then once somebody
said oh you should try this sometime
another friend of mine who actually was
losing his hair and I tried it and I've
been married to this ever since the
graves essential of my whole life is my
son and not just my son but I love when
my son jumps in in the morning and wakes
me up and hugs me I love when I get home
at the end of the day and he races
across the room to like jump up and grab
me just getting hugs from from my son
lakyn is the most rewarding
anything I can ever think of so I've
revealed my favorite bald man product
what's yours bald dudes all you guys
what do you use for that dome tell us
right here below or you can tweet it out
at hashtag GQ pin and be sure to
subscribe as well because we need some
more mad semantics